okay let's hear from some people in the
audience we'll go to our phone lines at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 first we'll go to the
4 1 5 area code caller from 4 1 5 what's
your name where are you calling from
today hey David this is Reggie from
Santa Cruz hey Reggie what's going on
hey um I just wanted to get your take on
a couple of concerns I had with Andrew
Yang's ubi proposal okay um so the first
concern is that it kind of has a
regressive slant to it because it takes
away from like food stamp expenditure
and things like that and so it feels
like the people who need it most
have to sort of make a trade-off which
feels kind of like the inverse of what
you might want from a ubi in that sense
yep I don't concern I mean I've pointed
out before that I'm open to replacing
and consolidating a lot of the
individual social welfare programs we
have with a sort of flat basic income if
that's the goal if the goal is let's
just reduce a lot of that sort of
bureaucratic expense and infrastructure
stop means testing things etc I'm open
to that but that's not really ubi
in the sense of lifting people from
where they are now that's replacing a
bunch of programs with one so I think
that we have to be clearer about what it
is we're trying to do if you replace
social welfare programs with ubi the
government saves some money but then
gives it also by not means testing ubi
to other people I think we need
something additive to actually improve
people's standard of living yeah I
totally agree with that but then my
other comment on the ubi proposal which
not a lot of people have talked about is
how it would work as a general stipend
because right now it's not a tax credit
which is nice in terms of its
distribution right people but it's a
flat amount to every single person now
there's kind of a problem with this with
regard to landlords because right now
landlords have so much bargaining power
with rent that if you don't have rent
control
just giving someone a flat amount of
money tells landlords
almost directly how much they might be
able to raise rent by yeah this I mean
that so I don't disagree with that but
that's not unique to ubi that's actually
an argument that's made much more
generally that's an argument that's made
when we talk about a minimum wage
increase although the difference with
the minimum wage increases that increase
only affects people who were earning
below the new minimum wage but I that
concern that that one is less unique to
ubi but Andrew yang is actually going to
be back on the show next week and I look
forward to talking with him about
exactly these issues I want to talk with
him about college tuition where I think
we disagree and start digging into some
of those proposals oh okay
great thanks for taking my call okay
appreciate the call Reggie from Santa
Cruz great to hear from you one of the
day's sponsors is privacy dot-com slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link